I've just told you a lot
about validation rules, and
I'd like you to start creating some for
shopping list plus plus.
Now writing validation rules
is pretty straightforward.
In fact if you'd like,
I could walk you through creating one
of these rules right now, start to end.
Here, let's take a look
at the user front node.
When you're writing the rules for
an object, take a look at the actual
object itself in the database.
So let's look at userFriends.
So here's the main node userFriends, and
it's going to have an arbitrary number
of children for every user that
has friends in the database.
And then for each user that has
friends,they in turn have a friends
list, and they're also going to
have arbitrary number of friends.
The friends themselves have pretty much
the same properties that we just saw.
Okay, so first things first,
let's map this out in the rules.
We can see here that
we have user friends.
Those two match.
And then here we have
a wildcard variable for
the users encoded email, and
then we have another wildcard variable
to represent each of the friends, and
then each friend will have this
structure of properties as matched here.
Okay, so it looks like pretty much
the structure matches the structure.
That's good.
Now this is not actually doing
any sort of validation yet.
Notice I haven't written
a single validation rule.
To start, we could write rules that make
sure that all of the correct properties
are present in the friend
encoded email object.
So I'll go ahead start by writing a new
data has children rule right here.
This rule will make sure that
all these properties exist And
also go ahead the write one for
the timestamp joined.
Now this only makes sure
that these properties exist.
It doesn't make sure that they
are the only properties that exist.
And it doesn't protect against
writing other arbitrary properties
that could be wrong.
So do that, we have to use the dollar
sign or wildcard variables as I
described earlier, so
I added those variables here.
At this point, you're completely
confirming the structure of
the user object.
Now you could write more specific
rules for each of these properties.
Generally, you could start by
doing a type related validations.
For example,
the name should be a string.
And just continuing down,
the email should also be a string,
has long to do with password is
a boolean, and timestamp is a number.
In addition, we could do
a further validation on the email
with the regular expression
I showed you before.
So it's a string, and its value
matches the format of an email.
And that's a pretty good start for
ensuring the structure
of the userFriends node.